a royal family united in grief and duty
for the funeral of queen elizabeth ii
welcome everyone to entertainment
tonight kevin frazier joins us from
london kev ten days of mourning has all
led to this michelle there is nothing
that can truly describe the spectacle
and the heartbreak that we saw today
here in london as the world said its
final goodbyes to the queen whose love
of country was only matched by her love
for her noun devastated family
[Music]
of the many poignant scenes today one of
the most heartbreaking was seeing the
queen's great great-grandchildren in
mourning
that seven-year-old princess charlotte
breaking down she and prince george
arrived with mom kate to westminster
abbey and inside the nine-year-old
prince in a navy suit solemnly sang
alongside dad william and seemed to get
emotional
charlotte's only jewelry a small diamond
brooch in the shape of a horseshoe a
tribute to her late gangan who loved
horses four-year-old prince louis did
not attend but katie nichol who wrote
the book on the new royals explains
charlotte and george's special
relationship we've always had an air and
a spirit the queen was supported by
princess margaret her sister
charles was supported by the princess
and william was supported up until
recently by harry's that notion of the
air and the spare is something that
we're now seeing continued in charlotte
and george and it's rather lovely we
just learned about the decision actually
this morning that they were going to
participate gail king with us today
weighing in on the children's presence
prince george is nine and he now is
second in line for the throne so
certainly he is being prepared the
children rode in a car chatting with
grandma camilla the car behind them
completely silent with megan and
countess sophie stoically staring out
different windows but when megan got
emotional today watch little charlotte
briefly turn towards her the duchess
responded with a slight smile unlike the
house of windsor's feuding brothers what
i didn't see was them together other
than in the procession william was able
to salute in uniform harry was not this
after charles requested the duke of
sussex where his military attire for
saturday's vigil today harry and megan
held hands but what was interesting the
royal seating plan it almost seemed like
every effort was being made so that
there wasn't an awkward moment where
they had to sit side by side at one
point charlotte was put in between them
inside saint george's william was
gracious towards his brother allowing
harry and meghan to take their seats
ahead of him a few special nods to her
majesty megan wore the pearl earrings
the queen gave her her dress a black
version of the stella mccartney cape
dress she wore to the queen's 92nd
birthday kate had on the queen's
necklace which diana previously wore
dye's brother charles spencer honoring
elizabeth with cufflinks bearing her
cipher princess dies private secretary
patrick jefferson and her biographer
tina brown gave us insights into where
the royal rift goes from here had megan
and harry studied diana's experience
carefully there's a lot there that might
have helped guide them in their own
relations with the royal family were
this men the fences
if ever there was a moment
when a reconciliation could happen this
is clearly the moment
[Applause]
king charles wiped back tears during the
one-hour service at westminster nora
o'donnell along with gail anchored live
coverage on cbs today to me he looked
ashen-faced it was like the weight of
all of this
came crashing down
there would have been dreading as i knew
a lot of people had
he's trained for this for a very long
time he's ready of course every detail
of the day was carefully planned
including the symbols on the queen's
coffin the scepter the orb and the
imperial crown i think they're probably
the most important symbols of monarchy
and i think that moment where they were
taken from the queen's coffin
put up on the high altar
they will then go back to the tower and
the next time we see them will of course
be at the coronation
for king charles iii
the wreath on top of the queen's coffin
included myrtle that was cut from a
plant that was grown from a sprig in her
wedding bouquet in 1947. charles also
wrote a note it said in loving and
devoted memory charles r the r stands
for rex or the latin word for king and
this got a lot of attention on twitter
for a moment a spider could be seen
crawling across the card as for this
moment
the bagpiper who closed the funeral is
the same piper who woke the queen up
every morning by playing for 15 minutes
outside her window he played on
elizabeth's final morning at balmoral an
estimated 4.1 billion people worldwide
watch today's ceremony tens of thousands
lined the streets for a glimpse of the
procession as for the guest list you're
talking about 500 heads of state
the emperor of japan president biden but
i think what we thought was most
interesting is to see all these royalty
loaded onto buses like the rest of us to
get here because that's how tight the
security was grey's alum sandra oh
attended as part of the canadian
delegation and british adventure host
bear grylls a leader in the uk version
of the boy scouts paid his respects but
it wasn't just the famous i thought wow
how extraordinary it is that her
majesty's legacy includes including
ordinary everyday australians to attend
her funeral i spoke to australian
dentist trudy lynn she works with
patients with special needs and was one
of the everyday heroes invited to be a
part of today's service she was only 25
when she taught up the mantle and such a
huge responsibility and so i find that
personally very inspiring as someone
that wants to follow in her footsteps
and continue to contribute to the
community
just before the queen service began i
was with famed british composer of
phantom of opera and cats andrew lloyd
webber he shared his own memories of
their unique bond you two had a special
relationship and she even came out to
your house a couple of times yes yes she
did um i wrote a song for
the last jubilee which was called sing
she came around to the house and we sang
it for her she had an enormous sense of
humor
someone who captured that warmth and
grace getty images royal photographer
for nearly 20 years chris jackson
one of my favorite pictures actually is
of prince george chatting to the queen
at princess charlotte's christening and
he's pointing up looking at her hat who
knows what they're saying but it's just
a lovely moment
what was it like when
prince phil was still here janelle is so
lucky to photograph prince philip and
the queen um for their 73rd wedding
anniversary and then prince philip is
opening up a card from his great
grandchildren and you can see the prince
kind of lights that when he opens the
card they gave strength to each other
throughout their life
and today the queen will be reunited
with her prince for eternity i think
that moment where the queen's coffin was
lowered down into the royal vault was
very very powerful what viewers may not
realize is that in that same royal vault
currently lying is the duke of
edinburgh's coffin and they will both be
interred together at this private
ceremony which won't be televised she
wanted that final journey to be made
with philip by her side
as the queen's coffin made its final
procession to windsor castle this
poignant image shows her pony emma and
the head groom saying a final goodbye
[Music]
also on hand her beloved corgis sandy
and mick prince william assures fans
they will be well taken care of
today's celebration of life is also an
opportunity to look back at the fun side
of the queen elizabeth had a wonderfully
wicked sense of humor and let it show
even getting both william and harry to
crack a smile while in a military lineup
in 2012 the queen's playful side was on
full display when she dropped into the
opening ceremony of the olympic games
with james bond what's she like in
private
very funny really very funny wants to
crack a joke and craft a joke about me
we're having our photographs taken and
she just went oh no he's the one that
doesn't smile
she doubled down on her acting skills
putting on a lighthearted brilliant
performance alongside paddington bear to
celebrate her platinum jubilee perhaps
you would like a marmalade sandwich
i always keep one for emergencies
so do i
i keep mine in here
she didn't carry a marmalade sandwich in
her purse darren mcgrady was her
majesty's personal chef for 11 years he
reveals some royal secrets on his
youtube channel and his cookbooks are
available on the website eating royally
i remember my first meeting actually it
wasn't quite a meeting i saw the queen
coming towards me with the corgis and
then as we got closer the dogs saw me
and then they started barking and then
all at once they all started running
towards me and instead of calling them
off the queen just burst out laughing
and i turned and i just ran and then
never got to meet the queen that day
despite the tiaras and crowns darren
said elizabeth's go-to breakfast was a
bowl of cereal and she wasn't against
eating out of good tupperware and
despite dedicating her life to serving
the crown she never took herself too
seriously
oh really
please
[Music]
you